and this is why when you are a guy who
you know is you and you're what five 170
right how you characterize doesn't
matter because boxing and [ __ ] and the
reason it made me laugh from the bottom
of my gut is that if you ever step to me
give a [ __ ] if we're in the theater
class yeah I'll give a [ __ ] if we're on
a cruise to the or where we are
respectful I'll fold you a full jet no
yes and I'll toss you on top of the
tallest building I see no have a look
around I laugh at that if there's a
two-story building the seams here what
are we on the third floor here yeah so
this has got three floors this place
yeah all the all the places in this
whole complex three pretty cool stuff
yeah there's lots of great [ __ ] outside
there's I as I was walking in I saw a
food truck yeah everyone was ordering
stuff yeah and careful now looks like
it's a good thing yeah if we were out
there and I was in line and I was like
yeah hi chicken Caesar no croutons and
then you walked up and you shoved me out
of the way and you look three food store
cool and I would just fold you and turn
you around and I would start spitting
and I go there it it and it's like oh
there's one and three stories up [ __ ]
you
he'd wake up gravel rash on the roof
just crumpled up against an air
conditioning unit what the [ __ ] a pity
you'll get gravel rash guys they'll be
up there tar in the gravel with their
hot mops and you'll go watch so [ __ ]
yeah you got a little you're hot it's
hot up there you got some tar on guitar
you got gravel ratchet bubbly yes little
bony of my pants yeah a little [ __ ] a
little [ __ ] in your pants listen I
appreciate what you're saying and I get
it I'm not a regular guy I got a lot of
tricks yeah yeah that's the same thing
as Chet I'll get will the word again
I've been sitting down the punches
lately doing a lot of sparring a
measuring distance who's the guy that I
say you can all unequivocally I always
give you props and I say if that goes to
a fight an organized fight and I would
love to see it happen maybe we can set
up some sort of charity I know what's
happening Brian's taking that [ __ ]
dudes head off who's that who do I say
that about CM Punk
okay
I don't know Brooks yes I always say
that Brian at 50 years old yeah you'd be
able to [ __ ] you'd be able to give CM
Punk a false sense of security
he'd come at you and then you throw one
of them box and Bob spin kicks like you
do on Instagram yeah get him into that
gravel rash you get him gravel round
nothing rash you know get him in the hot
mops in the black toilet somebody's
gonna fight again huh probably come on
that'll be fun it's a nice compliment
now yeah careful so what I'm gonna say
is I'll kick his ass and your [ __ ] that
[ __ ] both up
listen I'm oh hey how about this yeah
[ __ ] quote me I'll only fight CM Punk
if I'm fighting Bryan Callen at the same
time what do you mean because I want to
show people the difference so I'm just a
big what it Brennan and you as I walk in
here yeah here he is a whites a albino
Samoan the shaved polar bear what does a
polar bear do there's a polar bear do
any does he do any mixed martial arts in
LA does he do any lifting wax no what
does he do he drags walruses up on to
that's right he lives he hunts and he
lives yeah and that's what I do I hunt
and I live yeah and at 8:00 it's a it's
a regular day on the ice for me to drag
CM Punk and Bryan up out of the water
onto my iceberg and just pools and pools
of blood pools of blood regular day on
the ice regular day on the ice I gotta
eat what am I gonna let Brian go because
I'm eating CM Punk no you killed Bobo
I'll fight CM Punk so long as I'm
fighting bryan callen handicap match
okay that's who won won and you guys got
to wear matching [ __ ] [ __ ] tag to you
what the [ __ ] where you and CM Punk
now hey will what was the tag team where
they had the shoulder pads and spikes on
both road warriors yeah yeah yeah yeah
road warrior animal and roadway are not
one
what a rush I wear what I want what we
need you to wear yeah no you guys yeah
you guys weren't to wear but I want you
to wear like yeah you guys are gonna
wear spiky shoulder pads but I want the
spikes digs no I want you guys in
matching like killer beez outfits like B
Brian Blair and jump around though
CM Punk used to be a professional
wrestler and that's what I want you guys
can't move around it's just no it's just
a singlet you know it's just little too
short let's try striped with the killer
bees just like bees like black and
yellow and then you know some cute knee
pads and then wings maybe at the back
their wings if you want whatever some be
wings yes yes just for the entrance
right now and then and then you guys get
the ring and that's the only way I'll
fight CM Punk
all right okay is he fighting again
that's the rumor yeah all right
good luck you know big huge slope and
shaved albino Samoan polar bear okay now
let me ask you something I don't give a
[ __ ] how much boxing you alright hold on
did you do some boxing oh cool hey well
does it it when you're on you've been
working a ton on set does anyone are
like hey so does anyone talk about
fighting or [ __ ] with you ever there
me never no no no I'm a I'm a nice
gentle person I mom I know but you like
dudes are people like man no no never I
have a quiet
I haven't never cuffs you about the ears
no nobody cuffs me about the ears a
question no it's not a question yeah you
know because they're back your dream no
that never happens no for your face no
lightning for no grabs lightning fast
jabs yeah let's get in the parking lot
after this I'll bring the [ __ ] camera
with [ __ ] let's get it going I've
never fast let's get on the roof where
it's nice you mind you might take my
shirt off outside and inside of your
[ __ ] knees
why don't you have a look at my knees
those are big knees they might hurt my
foot yeah that might hurt looking
besides that bull heart for a cab
yeah you know I was at the airport yeah
and I got you something
you got me a gift yeah I got you a gift
seriously the airport all right
is that a snake
hey I'm a friend it's for you cuz those
it I was at the airport and I thought
you might enjoy that and I come bearing
gifts
Hollywood best woman yep so that was the
only one they had that's the only one
they had you got me what looks like an
Oscar mhm
it looks like an Oscar but it's not it
says Holly legal best woman it's his
best woman on it and that's for you why
would you do that because I wanted to
get you a nice gift from the airport is
your heaven - condescending gift uh yeah
and don't do that with your face Oh
as you know what I'm saying and that's
weird don't that's weird on search hold
on a second hold on I don't know if my
watch is quite I'm a check that was 2018
yeah are you saying that's insulting I'm
just saying that you gave me well let me
ask you a question Brian in 2017 what
would you consider the year 2018 I I
don't know that would be the what what
would we call that - here are the woman
just one year it's the future Brian and
future female and if you're gonna not be
a scumbag and you want to be equal yeah
- people like your wife yeah and you
know my girlfriends and your girlfriends
and Maya Angelou and my Angela and you
know I'm Julia Roberts and people like
that then you're gonna have to embrace
this so stop being a [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] I'm not I joined a song don't say
I'm at best why are you not a woman how
do you think cuz I'm a man with a huge
hold on hold on it's too heavy balls
that you have you that create a lot of
testosterone and semen okay but that
doesn't mean they're not trying to be
gross but that's it but that doesn't my
deal but that doesn't mean that you
can't be honored and excited by me
calling you a woman no I can't say that
your that's my face and I'm feet out
like a [ __ ] that maybe I like a
mother yeah that maybe that you're also
all they had left was woman and I mean I
should be happy I'm aggressive enough to
fantasize about punch you in the face
until you die so sort of so are some
women that's true well then what the
[ __ ] but I don't appreciate this you're
being turned this gift to you give me
and don't give that back to me if I give
you that back to you Brian if you give
that back to me I will insert it into
you
now here's that is that is how i'ma say
I'm being calm [ __ ] camera Brian I'm
being it all started in anywhere all I'm
saying you know that's not all I'm
saying is I gave you a gift if you
decide to return that gift to me that I
thought you would enjoy yeah careful now
careful careful because I'm gonna give
you another chance because what you just
did is I will take that gift yeah okay
careful insert it into Hey okay Brian
okay man as that would be gotta say that
you I think you're being a [ __ ]
bought fascism yeah you are you just
said you were gonna you went with your
finger you did a loop and you push
pointed you with your finger went up in
the air which means that clearly isn't
indication you're gonna stick it right
on myself that's not what it means then
what does it mean I would say you can
drop from this what you like well I I
got you a gift it says that it's the
best woman it's an Oscar but not quite
really yeah and you should be honored to
have that and it's [ __ ] and the
futures female yeah you find [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
okay you [ __ ] you just threatened and
if you don't if you don't take this gift
then you're not just a piece of [ __ ] the
[ __ ] thought fascist you're a
misogynist until suspenders insert this
e-mail and if you try to give it back to
me I'm being very calm when I say the
line I will insert a day that's three
times that you've threatened okay to to
essentially take me serious thing now
let's keep it back mmm I'm gonna keep it
over here and I'm gonna give it back to
you later no I want you to I want you to
feature prominently here in your Studios
I don't want that's they want you to
build a little shelf out of this now the
guy who makes this is a good guy
it took me a long time to etch that and
if you did not like that some guy makes
a bunch of those in the California
countryside please ask him for a
similarly affected and diseased panel of
wood that you can screw into there as a
little shelf to put your best woman
award on your finger out of my face bro
I'll [ __ ] shove it up your whole list
I'll shove it right up your [ __ ] you
just said Oh blatantly where that Titans
got little creases on the side where it
was put together because it was made far
away by children's little hands oh and
those little edges cut no and I'll
[ __ ] Ram it up your balloon knot and
it'll hurt to [ __ ] for weeks if I do
that oh well you're so aggressively
[ __ ] little brown balloon not don't
call it a brown thing like you know if
you took like bubblegum yeah
like chocolate do they make chocolate
gum I don't know dude and I'm sure that
I'm we're and then just take your your
nostril in your ear hairs go brink and
then just twist it into the [ __ ]
brown gum and that's that's a replica of
my my that's your [ __ ] and then take
that [ __ ] thing and try to put the
gum on it like a hat and you'll bleed
okay I'm gonna ask you oh man do a reset
yeah well no I don't want to start over
but I do want to start metaphorically
over because you're obviously got some
problems this is my funeral song yep
this was it is that it though
that's my that's my funeral it's your
funeral song and Chris and I would come
in are you guys carrying my coffin we're
gonna be floating next year coffin like
this were the only pallbearers now I
want to be wrapped like a mummy and you
guys are carrying me wrapped like a
mummy
yeah we're just making you float
shoulder my body's rigor mortis your
wife's crying yeah and then we do that
wink at my wife with my with me on your
shoulder wrapped in gauze you know you
know out here in LA in Southern
California they have those sign flippers
they have them other parts of the
country where it's like Subway sandwich
599 I got these new apartments that's
what we do with Brian's corpse [ __ ]
funeral and we just flip in the chicken
suits yeah what do you serve bacon to
white women are gonna make burritos
there you go there you go there you two
white women who went to Mexico are super
foodies hey you know what let's start a
restaurant did you feel [ __ ] loved it
yeah and now it opens just Walter flip
and Brian's body with chicken suits on
white women make burritos white crying
so hard yeah and then I bust out of the
gauze and I'm like psych both your
throats okay I drink your blood no
lobsters bugs out there yeah they do
well they're in the [ __ ] up about
animals I'm just talking about us why do
we call them bugs cuz they yeah I'm tell
you this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing shut up
Brian
what would take a while because and
everyone's gonna find out about this
because we're gonna sell tickets and
we're gonna have a pay-per-view it's
gonna be the first fighter in the kid
pay-per-view you're venturing into new
lands and you want to make some real
[ __ ] money yeah yeah we're gonna do a
pay-per-view and it's gonna be you and
me and it's gonna be we're gonna
incorporate a little of the you know the
the wrestling sports entertainment thing
we're gonna say that it's a No
Disqualification match right but MMA
rules No Disqualification and submission
or knockout only and then and then
you're gonna come at me with whatever
what's it gonna be now I'm gonna shock
and I'm gonna and I got considered right
and I'm gonna I'm gonna SWAT those away
and bat my eyes and it's not gonna be
fun to watch right on TV like he's never
fought what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do this
which is gonna be even more embarrassing
when I actually do get a hold of you and
just kick your legs out from under you
and then I start the game like depressed
yeah bring that up chin that
gameofthrones scene what's the guy's
name about the mountain
and then everyone's gonna come in with
hands people are gonna go get popcorn
and hot dogs because it's gonna take
about four hours of him of me just going
and again you're out cold in the first
30 seconds and then at around the four
hour mark you're just gonna hear and
then you're gonna get views that elapsed
in no it would be perverse is the
mountain rollin the exact eye pictures
now you got fast-forward cuz it's shown
the whole scene here we're even gonna do
it like outdoors like this you've gone
it at the Greek theater it here in LA
yeah I'm us and I'm gonna sit on top and
I'm also gonna rent a small person to
play with you know when it comes gonna
sit there like the Emperor yes and just
do the thumbs-up thumbs-down
yes when it comes to swordplay there we
go doesn't much matter size of the sword
matters
so there's Brian with that shitty bowl
cut and then here's will oh goes all
your teeth and then here's will and this
will take four hours with this imagine
this for four hours I gotta watch this
show now here's will doing this and oh
and dead Game of Thrones style Will
Sasso Bryan Callen oh that's gonna sell
paper views well died though and then he
died yeah yeah you're wait see I'm the
old rich dude that love you know that's
me right there and then we'll rent the
small guy out fine and you dropped that
outfit yeah is that [ __ ] John
Varvatos then we'll hire just some dime
piece yeah look at that quilted was that
quilted armor and yeah see that won't
happen do you be I'm not cool having my
hair gonna have to fill out some papers
before we start I'll tell you that right
now you might want to get your issues in
order I'm not gonna get your banking in
order you might want to fill it you
might want to get that will going now
I'm not doing it come to think about
though bro nothing to think about when
you see my back rip or I pull myself up
like a champ
like a chimp through 30 times fast while
talking to you
why wouldn't I give that to you as it's
a guess it's a gift it's a gift